[Music]
i like to do it the old school way with
respect
i can take things and put them together
and take them apart and make them better
and put them back together i respect the
craft so i don't want to minimize and
disrespect the value of each step of the
craft and
do by machine what should be done by
hand i've made a career out of making
colorful clothes like i'm a grown man
that makes colorful clothes you know
these clothes look so playful and easy
but it's such an intricate process and i
want people to know that this is what it
is this is luxury this is luxury
athleisure
for many generations african american
designers have not been
included within the conversation of high
fashion or considered high fashion in
recent years we see that emergence in
that movement to really kind of put
black designers on that same level that
we have cared for european designers in
that way
with black designers their work is just
as critical just this artistic
as any european or white designer or
non-black designer
i hope that black fashion is inspired by
my movements by the simplicity of what i
do by how clean my stuff is by my
ability to just put my flag in luxury
and say i'm a black designer and i do
luxury too
hello my name is fresh i'm the creator
i'm the ceo creative director for luxury
label rich fresh we specialize in luxury
athleisure and tailored garments i'm a
tailor by trade i'm a designer by choice
[Music]
we're downtown in the garment district
you know close proximity to where
everything is
there's just an energy that's downtown
there's a creative energy
we knew that we could find the type of
factory we need to build
yeah i think about a person that was
homeless at one point
didn't really have any money coming in
the fact that this person was relentless
and just determined to succeed and not
let rock bottom define him as an
individual i was a puff daddy
i always say i'm from memphis but i was
born in germany you know my parents were
both military they were in the army
a lot of my early memories are like
germany so like the colors on the
clothes that i used to see people
wearing the font was different the
advertisements were different the
architecture was different everything
was just different in germany than it
was in the u.s subconsciously it just
got planted there somewhere and i always
kind of revert back to this doesn't feel
like something you see in america it
feels like something you could see
in germany or abroad
once we moved to the states my first
grade was normal but i was bored i was
bored out of my skull
the second grade they put me in this
advanced class with second graders and
third graders who are really performing
on like a fifth and sixth grade level
and there was this girl who i had a
crush on
i knew i'm
one of the smartest kids at the school
and math is my thing so
the teacher asked if i would tutor her
and then at this moment where i heard
god and i have this thing from time to
time where i hear the voice of reason
that said
you're doing this all wrong she has a
higher purpose she has information that
you need to acquire
so the first day of tutoring as soon as
we sat down i just looked right in the
face and like you need to know math i'm
very very very good at this i got you i
suck at girls
how about we do an exchange i'll teach
you this you teach me that
she was like honestly it's the way you
dress like i think you dress different
girls will like you like you just you
dress like a kid
i said what's it called she said i think
it's called fashion that's it hmm
all right well let me uh see what this
fashion thing does
appreciate it first thing i do is i i
meet with the client ellis
all right man all right
i take their measurements
39
44 and three quarters
27 and a half
22
track jacket length at a 26 and a half
skin angle at an 11 and a half
and then we discuss colors concepts
maybe black kind of goes with that yeah
and that olive is nice nice papa color
nowadays too
yeah i like that then i put together a
digital mock-up of the tracksuit with
all the various colors you know that i'm
going to use for the base for the top
stripe the bottom stripe the piping all
the different layers of the tracksuit
then i'm going to send that to michelle
who's my production manager she takes
everything from concept to
production she is responsible for
delegating who gets what like i've got a
number of jacket tailors i've got a
number of pant tailors i've got a number
of hand finishers who are going to
complete the process
the first step of the production cycle
is the pattern you know you can't make
any garments without a pattern
so she's going to take it to our pattern
maker and show him all the various
measurements
he's going to build out the pattern draw
every piece out cut every piece
it's old-school process
of measurements marks measurements marks
measurements margin drawing lines
drawing lines drawing lines drawing
lines drawing lines drawing lines
cutting
that's your block that's your pattern
so the pattern has to get transferred to
the garment and oftentimes it'll just
get laid on top sailors are so precise
they don't even need to pin it and then
from there you've got to cut
out the fabric
it's a special grade of neoprene more
water repellent it's a little bit more
dense it's a lighter weight you know it
absorbs colors really well so and it has
a nice sheen to it you know it looks
really luxurious
my senior year in high school i was like
i'm gonna take home act just to
see if there's anything else i can learn
my teacher was out we had another
teacher who came in to instruct but they
couldn't sew so i volunteered to be that
person because i could sell better than
anyone else in the class
the kids would call me ralph they would
call me tommy because you know tommy
hilfiger was ralph lauren my brother
chase he used to dress real rough
camouflaged pants oversized and always
saw how he got dealt with and so one day
i was like hey bro we got to switch that
up
the first
moment i knew there was like something
different like other than the rest of
the kids that were playing basketball
and tennis and baseball in the
neighborhood was this dude made a pair
of moccasins and then took them to
school and was like selling them to kids
actually taking orders
so i started like dressing you know
styling them like the whole thing from
head to toe you're going to get your
hair color i'll get my hair cut we're
going to do this boom boom boom
and so i saw his image shift he was
perceived differently
and regarding
this new era that we're in this new
chapter
where you have
these black designers
really inserting themselves into the
luxury space
is quite a fascinating dichotomy i
applaud it they're really kind of
building on the shoulders of
african-american designers who couldn't
and couldn't really stay there for a
long time and have long-standing power
zelda wen valdez very much known in the
harlem realm of dressmaking and in new
york fashion specifically uptown she was
credited with producing manufacturing
the playboy costume kind of a heralding
figure within fashion and for african
americans because really she was a part
of several organizations that really
mobilized around the education of
african americans within dressmaking and
within the garment industry and giving
them new opportunities that most people
weren't even thinking
you have stephen burrows in the
1970s who rose to fame with one of the
most notorious fashion events on this
side of the pond the battle of
versailles in 1973 that took place at
the palace of versailles where you had
the american designers pitted against
the french designers stephen burroughs
was the only black designer present a
lot of things happened within his
journey
some things that were out of his control
you have to chalk it up to the system of
fashion that didn't allow him the
standing power
that someone like ralph lauren had
everything is custom everything is so
specific
we don't have an assembly line system
when it touches the tailor
it finishes with that tailor
the pattern maker is also cutting
the fabric so he's going to cut the
block that's going to be the trouser
he's going to cut the block and it's
going to be the jacket
there are a number of steps to go into
it
we've got to assemble
the sleeve panel this sleeve is a two
panel sleeve
so this is two different pieces that
have to be sewn together
we need to top stitch just to reinforce
the outer seam on on the sleeve we've
got a chest panel which takes into
account each of the track stripes you've
got a pocket that's cut into the lower
panel
on each side but again this pocket is
cut through the stripes they've got to
put each of these pieces together very
specifically
we've got our collar assembly
the outer collar we've got our inner
collar assembly the back has to be
assembled so
you know all the stripes have to be
built into
the back panel as well
there the zipper assembly with the
zipper facing is built in all the final
touches before it makes its way to hand
finishing
i got married young i got divorced john
but i got married when i was 20. so now
i'm 21
i'm starting this new business doing
alterations this is the only thing i
really know how to do and i figured you
know the goal is to get volume i need to
get money i started my first business
maybe six months later doing alterations
for dry cleaners two years i had it and
then i closed it which was a traumatic
experience but then i noticed a cool
thing people started calling me
not for the cleaning but for the
tailoring it was like hey man
sorry to hear about your cleaners but
can you still alter this suit i really
love the way you did this than the other
so i was like um i'm gonna position
myself as a concierge tailor and i'm
gonna just travel to people
before i got divorced i had a child so
right when my daughter was like six
months old me and her mom split that's
the first time i just thought about like
i don't have to do this thing here in
memphis like life is going to change
dramatically i don't have to do this
thing the way i've been doing it you
know i just got tired of being broke in
memphis then my brother lost his job in
nashville so i was like bro just you
know come back to memphis we'll figure
out what it is we would talk about
dreams and big things and like what
could one day be possible we just came
to the realization that it was where we
were didn't matter how progressive
we moved the environment was not going
to lend itself to the success that we
deserve we had to be somewhere else
let's go to the west coast
we hopped in the car and we just drove
for three days across the country landed
in san diego started up the old business
doing alterations for dry cleaners
and then you know disaster struck my
friends got divorced right when my
daughter was born so up to that point my
dad had never even seen my daughter and
then out of nowhere we get a call that
he's in the hospital and it's bad and he
dies
at 52.
it's out of nowhere i ended up losing
all my accounts with the dry cleaning
and stuff like my brain wasn't there i
didn't care about any of that anymore so
one day we decided to just take a drive
to los angeles and i had a client a rich
client he said he needed a bunch of
suits made
i was like
you talking my language jack
i used my money to front the cost to
produce all these suits which is all of
the money
that payment never got made so here i am
now
i ain't got no more money i went from
having eight thousand dollars just the
other day
so now i got like 200 bucks
i look up and
now i'm um
i'm homeless
i hear god and i hear this voice that
says
you know you're so mad you're just so
mad i'm just really disappointed in how
you've chosen to make this man your god
and not me
you go to this dude every day asking for
this money you ain't came to me not once
he cannot save you
i can save you you need to talk to me
and i listen to god i don't want to be
this guy rich who has just chased the
money but he lost his soul in the
process i want to be something different
so i want to change my name to fresh i
want to chase that the money's going to
come but let me just be focused on the
business and being different i left the
shelter with 300
and i told god i'm going to take this
measly ass 300
and i'm gonna turn this into a million
dollars in a year
the real kicker
was that track suit when he dropped a
track suit
i was like
that was it that was game over
i noticed this lady with a color block
sweater on and i just thought about how
cool it was that whoever designed that
sweater could design it one way but
change the colors and manipulate it to
create 10 000 different variations of
that one sweater
i thought about what i could create like
that and i came up with this pant that
had prominent stripes you know they were
like trousers but it was some color
blocking and i could design it one way
and make it in a bunch of different
colors and the material would be super
comfortable
then i followed up with a jacket just i
needed a jacket to wear with it
and i like retro style he did some suits
for draymond green and some other ball
players like right out the gate he was
doing some really dope suits rich fresh
made the suit he
can go by rich fresh he's from l.a well
he's not from l.a but he lives and works
out of la
it's really good
a rich fresh garment is not a rich first
garment without two indicating factors
one is this yellow tab
right on the side of this garment
there's a yellow grosgrain tab it's very
specific it's on the side of every
single rich fresh garment
in existence
on the trousers
as well as the jacket
on every garment whether it's a suit
jacket whether it's a robe i don't care
and then the second
thing there's always
rich fresh made in los angeles because
it is in fact made in los angeles and
people should be aware of that
and then it goes from there it's almost
the last step in the production process
you've got the waistband this is the
trouser waistband it's got a built-in
hook and eye closure
if you do lose a little bit of weight
you can actually cinch this and it'll
take it in three quarters of an inch on
each side
[Music]
once the sewing process is done it goes
to one of the hand finishing titles
there's a lot of hand work even on a
tracksuit like the hem on these trousers
is done by hand there's an insane amount
of hand finishing on the insides of the
jackets because it's unlined so when you
open it it's beautiful
once i'm presenting the suit to the
client you know it's a full-on
presentation so it's a very minimal
garment bag you don't know what to
expect i kind of like that element of
surprise you didn't see it all did you
yeah great great great remember what we
discussed yes i'm from memphis
i'm gonna say something slick what did
we discuss
and then i'm going to open it and the
client is usually going to scream
like this
man i see this
or exhale real heavily
there's always a moment of drama every
time i unzip and
fold it back oh good it wasn't by chance
bro my chance bro some ideas
so i let them have that moment
oh 100 oh wow
100 percent right
oh like you don't have to think about it
i'm gonna make sure that
you know everything fits the way it's
supposed to
and again if anything needs to be
modified
now is the time
um but if not
we shake hands we hug it out and they
take it with you noticed it but i'm like
i'm just taking all of it and taking all
of it in
my hope is that they will be given more
and more opportunities to flex their
skills to show how dynamic they are and
what new fresh elements of art they can
bring to the fashion industry
it's kind of like a pursuit of happiness
story almost
you know and like that was one of his
favorite movies not even live he watched
it so much he used to get on my nerves
it became part of his story
one of the most important things i could
take away on an entrepreneurial level
and as a businessman is just dream big
and and go after your goals the only one
that can stop you from becoming
successful is yourself
when i started i had no idea was going
to turn into
this which is the tracksuit empire
i don't have any investors all this is
all money in this is me going out and
hustling bringing that money back and
just building building it building it
there's so much more beyond this guy
there's really no telling what he would
come up with but we do know whatever he
comes up with is going to be dope
so
yeah there's really there's no limit you
can't put them in the box
you can't put a you can't put a sky over
them because he's going to bust through
it
[Music]
you